-It's time for "Tonight Show
Stocking Stuffers"!
Here we go!
♪ It's "The Tonight Show" ♪
-♪ Stocking stuffers ♪
-Now, there is no need to check
under your seats for this one.
Every night
until Christmas break,
we're giving away
an awesome gift
to every single person
in our studio audience.
You guys excited?
You guys ready?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys want to see what you're
going to take home tonight?
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Tonight's stocking stuffer is...
a Nintendo Switch,
OLED-model system,
"Splatoon 3" game,
and a 3-month subscription to
Nintendo Switch online.
-That's right, Jimmy.
This holiday, splat the halls
with "Splatoon 3,"
the new game from Nintendo
where you compete with friends
and splash the most ink.
Play on your TV
or handheld or tabletop
with the Nintendo Switch
OLED mode.
Who knows?
You may even get
splatted by Jimmy
when he's playing online,
via Nintendo Switch online,
which means you'll all get,
for free for three months,
so much fun.
Jimmy?
-Thank you!
Thank you to our friends
at Nintendo.
Enjoy your gift, guys.
We'll be right back with
Kate Hudson!
Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪